at 4 30 CCSD superintendent Dr Jesus  Jara one step closer to securing a new  contract to continue leading CCSD the  fifth largest school district in the  country this comes after a tumultuous  year for the superintendent who was  actually fired by the board then brought  back just a few weeks later last night  the board voted in favor of his  performance and he responded by saying  he is looking forward to Leading The  District next week the school district  will evaluate a new contract for the  superintendent if it's passed jara's  salary will increase to 395 thousand he  will also be eligible for a 76 thousand  dollar bonus each year the  superintendent would also receive perks  for travel the contract would run  through June 30th 2026.